Celui là est le pire progrès.
Mais c'est à cause de cela.
C'est terrible, c'est terrible à certains endroits, mais ça s'est transformé en Bishanko.
N'y a-t-il pas quelque chose qui s'appelle teru ?
Oui
Oh, c'est un village, tout le monde des autres soutiens-gorge.
Cela ressemble à cet immeuble.
De manière générale, mettez un ku devant.
C'est devenu comme un brise-vent.
Je pense qu'il valait mieux venir ici.
Originaire de Tokyo
Qu'essayes-tu de dire, Ishikawa ?
Les maisons joliment construites de Noto sont alignées les unes à côté des autres.
Je veux vraiment créer une forme qui semble être là.
Si le bâtiment devient vacant et qu'un certain temps s'écoule, il sera démoli.
Quand on le range, le paysage urbain semble un peu
Cela signifie qu'il ne sera plus maintenu.
C'est trop de gaspillage
n'ai pas
JA